hello everyone this game was played in
1956 it was played between Donald Byrne
and the 13 year old Bobby Fischer and a
lot of you may think that everyone in
the world always knew who Bobby Fischer
was but it was only after this game was
played that everyone in the world knew
who Bobby Fischer was and Bobby wasn't
the favorite in this game but Donald
Winer was actually a favorite even
though Bobby was a very perspective
young chess chess player in the Junior
US Champion Donald Byrne was actually a
multiple times
senior US Champion and he also almost
had his Grandmaster title at the time
this game was played but the tournament
was actually won by Samuel Reshevsky and
Bobby Fischer got ninth place in this
tournament but he didn't produce this
beautiful game that was later called the
game of the century so let's see this
game as the odds wine is white and Bobby
Fischer is black we have nice to f3
Knight to f6 c4 g6 Knight to c3 Bishop
to g7 d4 - Bobby castles Bishop to f4
about Bobby goes for the groom for this
and d5 Queen to b3 and here Bobby plays
D captures on c4 which is the which is a
an important decision because after D
captures on c4 and this is the Queen
recaptures then after e3 is play then
this Bishop will have to be developed
somewhere other than c4 so it's kind of
a temple move so we have D captures on
c4 Queen captures on c4 and now c6 this
defense this c7 pawn because the Queen
and the bishop were attacking us and
also prevents this knife from going to
be 5 or d5 in the future we have e4
Knight B to d7
preparing night to b6 rook to d1 what we
place a knight to be 6 and the barn
plays Queen to c5 barn could have played
the Queen back to b3 but this allows the
Bishop d6 for the tempo and welcome
Baron has another idea what he plays
going to c5 which will see very soon
Bobby plays the Bishop to g4 and here a
barn plays Bishop to g5 and when this
move Baron is actually breaking the most
fundamental rule in chess which is
moving the same piece twice in the
opening and he does it with an idea of
kind of caressing this this
seven point but Bobby punishes this move
like a 13 year old boss that he was and
he plays Knight to a4 and this is a well
this is a quite a move if you look at it
what is it does seem like Weston simply
capture this pawn with this night would
not get résumé for but let's see what
happens if he does if Knight captures on
a4 then nice captures on e4 and this is
a double attack on the Queen and the
bishop and with if what would play this
perfectly it would still be better for
black for example if Queen captures on
e7 a bishop would capture on f3 and
after Queen Katharine b8 and rook
captures and EH the bishop would capture
and e8 and now Bishop casters on d1 with
an attack on this night on a4 so nice to
see three and now simply rook capture
son be a nice capture son d1 and now
this rook to e8 move is very good for
black so what has to defend against
threats like night to g3 and after
something like Bishop to e2 simply
Bishop captures on d4 and this is this
when the pawn for Fisher and this is a
better for black this is probably
winning for black so after this Knight
to a4 moved on Baron doesn't capture the
night he plays he plays Queen to a 3 and
now favorite place to Knight captures on
c3 and the course of the Queen can't
capture the nice because a nice cares
only for would again be a double attack
on the Queen and this Bishop on g5 so he
plays big captures on c3 and office
replacing light captures only for
attacking that Bishop on g5
but it a white can still capture this
pawn on e7 which which burn does he
plays Bishop captures on e7 and it seems
like is the winning the exchange here
after the Queen moose is going to
capture the rockin s8 so Fischer plays
Queen to b6 so let's see what happens if
a barn were to take this rockin f8 if
Bishop captures a nice age then Fischer
would play Bishop captures anaphase
again now with the tempo on the Queen on
a3 and after after what if why so play
the best move here like Queen to b3 then
simply this rook the EH move is again
extremely good for black so after Queen
captures on b6 a casters and b6 simply
Bishop to e2 because he white has to
defend against this threat
nice casters on c3 and this is again a
lot better for black he's upon up and
white King is still in the center and
it's going to be very hard to play this
so let's see after Queen to b6 Barnes
isn't captured this rock and I faith he
played Bishop to c4 developing and
preparing to castle so Fischer plays
Knight captures on c3 and well it seems
like he's altering the night here but
he's really not if Queen captures is
nice and simply request the yeas and
he's winning with winning the material
back and he will be upon up so after
Knight captures on c3 a barn and got a
very very nice idea with Bishop to c5 in
attacking Fisher's Queen Sofia plays an
intermezzo he plays rook to e8 check it
goes to f1 and now as they say if this
game is indeed called the game of the
century then Fischer's next move is
called the move of the century and
Fischer plays Bishop to e6 and now black
has I mean White has a lot of options
here I mean one of the options is pretty
obvious before capture screen and b6 but
there are other options for example a
white can capture this bishop on e6 and
then the Queen is still at active course
so let's see what happens if this is
played if Bishop captures only six then
extra the Fischer actually has a forced
checkmate in six moves after Queen Queen
to b5 check King to g1 a nice to eat to
check at King gets to go back to f1 nice
the g3 with a double check from the
knight and the Queen so King goes back
to g1 and now the very nice philidor's
made Queens f1 forcing White's to
capture the Queen rook captures on s1
and not simply ignites the e2 is a very
nice smothered mate so obviously blacks
can obviously white cannot play a bit of
captures on e6 but let's see that's the
Queen casters on a c3 idea if if Queen
were to capture on c3 then simply Queen
captures on c5 and now this Bishop is
pinned and also its attacks twice and if
white captures the queen of the files
and simply difficult capture the screen
three and again black is better here so
after Bishop to e6 it doesn't really
seem like her whites has any other moves
but to capture the Queen so that's
exactly what Donald Byrne does he plays
Bishop captures Queen nb6 but this
allows Fischer to create one of the one
of the greatest attacks ever seen
he plays Bishop casters on c4 with Czech
and the King has to go to g1 and how
nice they do check and now Fischer
forces the white king into a windmill we
have King to f1 now nice capture Sundy
for first with Czech and Fisher could
have played a nice the c3 check and then
pick up a rock but he didn't pick up
this pawn just to grab a point there's a
there's a higher purpose to this move
which we'll see later we have King back
to g1 now 92 check back again into f1
and now Knight to c3 check and the King
has to go back to g1 and now Fischer
doesn't capture this route but he plays
a captors on v6 and now attacking the
Queen and now you see the Queen cannot
capture this night because that's why
favor grab this point so the bishop
would be defending the knight on c3
so very nice moves by Bobby we have
Queen to b4 and now again not capturing
the row can be won but first improving
the position rook to a4 now protecting
the bishop so Queen captures on b6 and
only now Katherine rule can be won so
rook captures and night gathers on d1 we
have a ch3 by on wants to develop in
some way we have rook captures in a -
King to h2 and now Knight captures nf1
nf2 and you can see well Bobby doesn't
have a queen but the material is highly
in the hand blacks favor I would have
rook to e1 Bobby captures rook captures
any one night first Queen to d8 check
Bishop to f8 blocking and now Knight
captures on e 1 and if you look at this
position
well white pretty much only has the
knight and the Queen against a rook a
bishops pair and a nice so this will be
this is impossible to play for white but
dama barn decides to try and play this
we have Bishop to d5
9:33 now what only chance would be if
Bobby would I don't know fall asleep for
three moves and allow white to play nice
here tonight here and then capture on f8
maybe but still he continues to play
this so we have nice to be for Queen CBS
trying to grab that b7 point we have b5h
for trying to break open with h5 plus
special place based h5 himself and now
why it really doesn't have any moves but
he tries he tries nice to e5 now going
for this Knight to d7 idea but Bobby
Bobby finishes the game extremely nice
he plays King to g7 and then now it's
nice to nice to discern and simply
Bishop to d6 which Czech picks up the
Queen so barn tries to play King to G 1
and we have Bishop to c5 check and now
the king is going into the mating net
came to F 1 night 2 G 3 woods check King
to e1 Bishop to b4 with check King to D
1 Bishop to b3 was checking to see 1 we
have an ID to check King b1 Knight to c3
check King has to go to c1 and now a
very nice finishing move rook to c2
checkmate
and yeah a beautiful game definitely
deserving deserving of the name the game
of the century and this was it like I
said it was only after this game that
everybody in the world heard who Fischer
was and I think this was Bobby's last
tournament that he wasn't contending for
the first place one year later he he
himself was the United States Champion
and he won the title I believe it was a
seven race times in a row before he
stopped playing it all together and yeah
a beautiful game I do hope you enjoyed
it and and as usual you can check two of
my previous videos here and yeah thank
y'all for watching and I will see you
soon